questions
right welcome to the second talk of this
morning so we are going to continue with
the Microsoft Invasion this morning and
uh we now have ching and Chang from uh
from the Redmond group and he's a senior
researcher there and he's going to talk
about game theoretic approach to
reinforcement learning offline
reinforcement advantages
so hi everyone so I'm China I'm from the
robot learning group in Redmond
um so now I'm going to switch the topic
so like so didn't talk about like
Interactive Learning for like decision
making right so here I'm going to talk
about something that's not interacting
at all so so this is the approach that
we have for offline RL
uh so before I start I want to kind of
like thank my co-author so like uh ten
young none and Alec uh like all
contributed greatly to this project
so the main motivation of this work is
uh trying to make a sequential decisions
in real world problems so this include
applications such as building Healthcare
systems like virtual assistants or
robotic systems uh so well in theory we
think that yeah IO is a very nice
firmware designed to let's say learn
policies for interaction and and it's
ideally for the like application like
this but in practice like it faces very
kind various kind of difficulties when
you actually try to apply it
so we know that RL needs a lot of like
samples and competition but in addition
to that like one key challenge that we
found in practice is that like uh the
data we can collect uh often do not have
enough diversity or coverage uh that we
need in the theory and that is because
that uh
the decision and make it you're making
real world you often carry like real
consequences as a result we can now run
just like the exploration policy or like
a random policy to collect data but
often we can only use a policy that can
say meet certain requirements such as
safety or being ethical to collect data
and that significantly limited data
diversity that we can collect so there
is so we need to think about a way to
decide algorithm that can deal with such
a systematic bias in the data
distribution that we have
so this brings out the framework of
offline RL which is designed ideally to
learn policy uh regardless of the data
distribution
and so this is nice but like it's a very
difficult question and and the core
difficulties come from that ideally a
certain idea but in general if we don't
have uh enough data coverage then it is
impossible to estimate even let's say
how policy will perform so it kind of
lacks the objectives right so now we are
talking about how to uh optimize policy
without objectives so just give you an
example let's say I want to learn like a
safe driving policy let's say for taxi
uh but all the data I collected are safe
dropping behaviors so now I have a
candidate policy I want to just even to
figure out whether that's a safe or not
safe and that's just not possible
because there's no unsafe driving
examples in my data set right so this is
a fundamental issue that we have in
offline RL uh so the good thing is that
we kind of have now they have a
principle to deal with this issue which
is ideal pessimism so uh here the main
uh idea is to think about let the agent
to think about the worst case for the
scenario that we don't have data and we
can choose to optimize for performance
lower bound uh instead of the True
Performance and that's something we can
estimate
but this is not a full answer because
there are many different ways that we
can use to define what we mean by worst
case and to construct the lower bounds
and different choice will have different
thread level between conservatives and
engineerizations uh let's go back to the
previous driving example so suppose that
we let the agent imagine the worst case
outcome such as like the classical to
crash onto the road and if the agent
just devil is slightly from the action
is in the data then the agent training
this way will just basically tend to
overfit the data that we have and we now
know how to behave if we put it under a
slightly different traffic condition
right and on the other hand we also
don't want the agent to just 9 to
believe that uh action is not covered by
the data are always good actions
so the main purpose of today's talk is
to introduce a different perspective and
uh of which is this again theoretical
approach uh and we found that this
perspective has been very useful to us
in income I clarifying some of the
difficulties and complexities of offline
RL and just make it very simple and this
uh framework can also be used to
systematically design a new offline
algorithms
the key idea here is to friend offline
RL as a two player again between the IR
agent and the fictitious adversary which
uh whose role is trying to kind of model
the uncertainty due to missing data
coverage
and so when given with a policy from the
learner uh the adversary you basically
would choose the hypothesis uh from a
class of hypothesis and such that it
will give the worst case performance
estimate so these hypothesis you can
think about they are let's say uh models
of Dynamics or models of value functions
in RL and uh we show that if we let the
learner to optimize the lower bound
constructed in this adversarial way then
the learner can have a preferable
guarantee in terms of performance even
when there is no let's say assumption on
the data coverage
uh so so if you compare this framework
with let's say other purchases of IO one
of the main advantage here is that uh
here the uh it allows to convert
systematically reason about the lower
Bound in a way that is consistent with
our prior on the hypothesis class and so
this is very nice because that now we'll
have a very natural uh trade-off between
generalization and conservatism
so for example if the learner takes
actions that will lead to scenarios
where our hypothesis class which are
function approximator that cannot
generalize then naturally this lower
bound will become conservative because
in that places the adversary uh have
like stronger power on the other hand if
the agent visits some places which our
functions can predict well then uh the
Northbound will naturally be typed even
though those are the scenarios where we
have like very low or zero data density
so uh
so what it means as a whole is that if
we train a ledger in this way it can
essentially Leverage The Generation
ability of our function class in this
hypothesis class uh to kind of like
learn policy that can generate to like a
wider set of scenarios beyond the data
coverage
so
yeah so the outline for this talk uh so
I'm going to first uh introduce this
like again theoretic framework a little
more details to be more precise and then
I'm going to talk about two different
versions of it one is based on absolute
pessimism and the other one is based on
relative pessimism in particular I will
show that the formulation of the version
based on relative transition has a very
nice property that we call robust policy
Improvement and what it means is that if
we if the algorithm has this property
RPI
then the policy learned by the agent can
preferably be better than the data
collection policy regardless how we
select the hyper parameters so this is a
very nice property in practice because I
selecting type apparenters purely
offline is a very difficult problem
uh by the way so feel free to interrupt
me if you have any questions
all right so let's try to make the
problem more concrete so in this talk
I'm going to consider the typical MPP
settings so this uh s is a state space
and you take an action go to the next
state and followed by this markovian
transition kernel you'll get the reward
and so we assume that and we're going to
consider the infinite Horizon discounted
version of this so since we are going to
consider offline RL I'm going to assume
that we have a data set collected by
running a behavior policy in this NDP
and starting from initial stay at zero
so we assume that this s0 is known to
the agent but you can relax these two uh
let's say to have a initial State
distribution and then you have some
samples of that so this is just to make
the presentation cleaner
and the goal of the agent is trying to
find a policy to maximize the discounted
return which is defined like this by the
reward and he has to do so without ever
interacting with the environment but
only looking at this data set collected
by the behavior Plus
all right
uh so in this talk I'm going to focus
mostly on the model 3 version of our
framework uh but at the end of the talk
I'm going to give you some things about
how you can easily extend it to the
model base
and so since I'm talking about model 3 I
need to Define some notation for that so
I'm going to use T pi to define a domain
backup and use qpi to denote the Q
function of a policy and just as a
reminder that the return want to
optimize equal is equal to Q Pi
evaluated at 0. and I'm going to assume
that the agent is given with this
function class capital F of function of
stay and action and this function class
was satisfy the common assumption that
we need which is realizability which
says that the Q Pi belongs to this
function class or in the complete this
assumption which means that the
background of this function class will
also be within this function class and
this assumption can be relaxed to be the
approximative version as well and things
will go through so I'm going to make the
exact one so things are clear
so uh our two player again is formally a
stacker bracket uh so what it means is
that it's a sequential gap between a
leader and a flower and in this scan the
leader will place the first and the
follower plays a second after observing
uh the decision made by the leader and
uh so this is a generalization of the
Zero Sum getting the sense that now
these two players uh can uh basically
optimize for different objectives
rather than the opposite of the other so
each game here is defined by an
objective five and then a regularization
turn e which is forcing a data
consistency so we let the ages of the
agent of the are origin which is a
learner here to be the leader and his
goal is trying to optimize policy to
maximize a lower bound constructed by
this adversary uh on the other hand
uh we led the adversary to play the
second to be the follower and so we will
try to basically when when he sees uh
the policy from the agent it will try to
find a hypothesis which in our case will
be the function of state and action the
value function uh to minimize this uh
standard code so we have the objective
five which both player competes and plus
a regretation turned out enforce they
had consistency
and here beta is essentially the hyper
parameter deck control uh how uh
consistent we want uh the hypothesis to
be with the data
okay so this might sound a bit like kind
of abstract so let me try to introduce
the the first example of first version
of our written uh that I'm going to talk
about in the first half of the talk so
this algorithm is something we call the
absolute pessimism again and this is
defined by this particular file and
regretation so since we are talking
about model free algorithm about
learning values as our hypothesis class
so this uh using the Belmont error on
the data set uh or data distribution
will be a natural candidate to be let's
say to force this hypothesis to be data
consistent right this is how it is
defined
so on the other hand the reason why we
choose this particular file is because
that we want to optimize for the
performance like the retention pi and we
know that General Pi is equal to Q Pi
evaluated at 0 and PI right and if you
see this this takes the exact like
algebraic phone as a file we choose up
here if we just replace let's say uh f
with a Q Pi here we get a 7g right and
so by this algebraic uh equivalence and
then we we can show that by a property
of design two player game which we call
the pessimist and Lemma then if we use
this equivalence then the player in
these two player again sorry the
learning needs to play again will be
essentially optimize the lower bound of
the performance uh that of 0 pi
yeah so think about f as a estimation of
your guess of Q
okay
and then uh since we're optimizing lower
bound and then by the optimality of like
optimizing lower bounds right so so uh
we are basically uh Computing let's say
the worst case then you can easily use
show that it's similar to the reverse of
what it used to be proof uh so uh you
can show that now you can have a regular
guarantee with any comparator and now
the gap of this regret will depends on
basically uh how well you can estimate
the comparison's performance with this
pessimistic intelligence step right so
you can now think about that what it
means is that uh if my uh if the
comparator can be well estimated by the
data then the policy learning this
approach what can essentially have like
small regrets with respect to that
comparator and this is kind of what we
naturally hope for for offline RL
questions no no okay
yeah or fellow leaders so
that's the file already incorporates the
minimization from the anniversary
perspective so when you try to
uh the game formulation yeah so the file
already incorporates the the mean mean
so the definition of fight alone is a
five functional tie an F together so
that definition doesn't incorporate uh
the minimization the learner will
optimize five evaluate and F Pi where F
Pi includes the minimization I see
okay
so let me use a visualization to kind of
help you to kind of understand how these
uh two-player game works
um so here we consider like a offline
bending problem which is like a very
special place
um and the way I'm going to discuss this
is time to compare this absolute
pessimism again with a more common
approach offline R which is called
point-wise specimension uh this is
essentially the principle that is behind
algorithm that use a bonuses or
truncation to be less pessimistic or it
comes from the upper lower bound
so uh in this example uh uh I suppose
that there are two hypotheses that are
data consistent for Simplicity and so if
you think about uh lower bound and based
on the ideal point-wise past mission the
essentially what it does is that for
every action that we're going to pick we
can start let's say yeah between these
two hypotheses what is the lowest value
and doing it Point wisely and then we
get this at Red objective right so we
can basically optimize this objective
and get a policy that is maximizing it
and by doing so we can kind of guarantee
similarly that uh the learn policy can
compare with the best policy that can be
expanded by the data because it's also
optimizing a lower bump but there's a
one caveat in this like common approach
which is that as you see in this figure
this red objective does not belong to
our hypothesis class which means that uh
the agent can potentially be optimizing
something that is overly pessimistic and
for example in this uh in this Idol
problem
we know from a hypothesis class that
either taking like very small actions or
taking very large actions can be bad but
they cannot be best simultaneously but
these are red lines suggests that like
all both of them can be bad right so
this if you turn into let's say the real
Theory why what happens is that it will
largely increase the size of let's say
adversary hypothesis that you have to
compete with
rather than the one you started with
on the other hand uh this again
theoretical approach will directly
optimize uh for hypothesis within your
prior class and it goes because God is
trying to find a policy that can work
well with either of these hypothesis and
in general this will lead to a
stochastic optimal policy because of
this adversarial nature of training on
the other hand for the plain wise
version is likely to lead to a
deterministic policy uh but the benefit
of the the the approach on the right
hand side is essentially that because we
are dealing with directly uh the
original crystal hypothesis which have a
prior about the problem the learn policy
can more can better be genres better and
be less conservative
okay so now we kind of understand that
the basic about how these two player
games work so let me show you how we can
kind of solve this problem and get a
policy from it right because I want to
talk about a very like information
theoretical so far
um so the main idea we're going to have
here is optimization algorithm based on
the a very different type no regret and
best response reduction in online
learning
so this is an iterative algorithm so in
every iteration we have a policy funded
learner uh we are going to first do a
pessimistic policy event step which is
basically calling an oracle to solve the
objective function uh sorry the
basically the optimization problem of
the follower and once we do that we get
the hypothesis F which in our case again
is this a function of State action which
requires is an estimation of the Q
function
so now the next step given this i f
we're going to call a No Regret
Optimizer and to by basically treating
this as a utility function in an online
learning problem
and so one thing you can use for example
would be let's say follow the regress
leader and this will lead to the update
rule that like this
and we're going to repeat this process
for k iterations at the end we let the
learner to kind of like output the
uniform of mixtures uh or policies uh
generated by this uh I mean iteration
process so this is a policy that the
learner is going to put up at the end
and apply to the real environment
so I haven't I been very specifically
here but the idea here is that uh given
an F uh every round the uh you get an f
and and then we Define our learning
problem for every state
so f is a functional State and action
and we trade F give fix a state now the
function over action uh uh is kind of
with your f as a utility over those
actions and then so uh every round you
get different apps so it kind of like a
online learning problem with uh you can
like ever several utilities and they
want to have no regret for every state
uh with respect to that sequence of
utilities
okay so so this is this part is like a
full information online problem but just
with uh potentially like changing laws
and for the uh absolute uh pessimism
again I talked about earlier uh this
algorithm is known as a pessimistic
um soft policy iteration and this is a
computationally efficient preferably uh
if the mdp is linear because these two
steps can actually have closed one
solution
is this like a
lower
conversation
yeah you can think about like it's like
like uh yeah so so let's say if you do
the typical let's say policy temperature
you want to let's say indirectly
maximize uh the uh the value you know
the critic right but here because these
are critics being Chosen adversarily and
so it's basically what's changed across
it's not like kind of sort of like
witness different entities during this
apartment setup so you want to kind of
run run like the optimization algorithm
that is uh robust to this adversarial
sequence and that's why we need to let's
say not really do a hard next but kind
of doing itself next
uh if you think about that
any other questions
okay
so now uh let me show you like the exact
field guarantees that we can have for
the entire uh absolute messages
so here we showed that uh if we make the
Assumption of this function class F uh
satisfy the realizability and complete
assumption then we can show that when we
choose the right beta value according to
this formula then uh the regret of this
learn policy which is this mixture of
like a positive generated during the
optimization we have a regret bound to
any comparator and this upper bound has
three turns
so the first current is the common uh
statistical error due to concentration
the second part is what we call the
outlet support generalization and we
just measured in terms of the Belmont
error of the hypothesis that uh it
closes during optimization
uh the important part about this uh
expression is that we only measure this
error at the basically stand actions
where our function class cannot generate
so this can be potentially like a
smaller than let's say places where we
have low data density and this is
reflected in this more generalized
definition of concentration coefficient
C
um these are kind of like the former way
to show that yeah we are leveraging the
generational ability of our function
class uh to reason about what is being
in support or can I okay generalize
versus other support rather than just
like viewing defining that based on the
data density
and finally we have this optimization
error and this comes from design no
regret part of its let's say no regret
and best response reduction and so if we
uh let's update the policy by a normal
gravity Minister and if that what it
means is that the record will be
sublinear in optimization and this part
will essentially vanish as we run more
iterations
okay
uh so let me give you some like high
level idea about why that performance uh
guarantee is true
um so it will only take three sites so
the first thing we do is that we just
substitute the definition of this
mixture policy so that will be an
average of this like uh the second
policy that we generate
they are going to add And subscribe a
bunch of different terms so I'm going to
define something called RK which is you
can think about as like the effective
reward that this hypothesis FK which is
adversary closing witness
um so uh so this is a FK this is a
reward such that FK is a real Q function
of this policy
um and we also add and subtract the uh
the lower bound that we estimate which
is f
so now we have three turns and I'm just
going to rewrite that in a nicer form so
the first time can be written as a
Belmont error of this FK evaluated at
the the comparatus distribution the
second part if you rewrite it uh then it
can be written as a regret in this
online learning problem created by
optimization so here basically FK is
being used as a utility and inside Pi is
essentially a comparative policy that's
it for every state in this online
learning problem that we create during
optimization and the last term is the
difference between our lower bound and
the real one right so because we are
doing a lower back estimation so this
part will be negative
and then we can just split the first
line into two parts into the interpread
error and our support error of the
Batman error this is how we get this and
this regret part can is actually be
upper bounded by the regret upper bound
of our Optimizer and that's how we get
the entire thing
so far
uh oh yeah so we are being we are doing
the
so because we choose this objective and
so when we actually solve this uh
pessimistic uh let's say this
adversarial uh evaluation step from the
adversary uh basically we can show that
this fight uh under this F5 chosen by
the adversary or forms to the lower
bound of performance
serious Choice yeah
but
it's been the first to use it
the right term can explain that right so
basically uh the return hat is inside
like the met the expected Batman error
under the distribution right so you
basically speed that split that
expectation uh onto two parts like one
is under a set that we have let's say
low error and the other one is under the
set that we have a higher error which is
always a property right so like button
is a song over like waiting sound over
let's say this error with with it by the
they say that this distribution right
just I split the sign in two parts and
for the parts which we have let's say uh
kind of high higher confidence because
they are closer to the data distribution
and closer to basically the region where
uh uh our function kind agrees and
that's kind of where we kind of have the
let's say the typical regression let's
say error which is this in simple part
and we kind of basically rewrite the
part that is I mean that we cannot
control as the outer separate part and
uh so this is some sound this like split
it's something that you can choose kind
of like in the hindsight it doesn't
require it's design analysis tool and
that's why we have these two terms
the newly says
uh the new question
so mu is supposed to be the behavior
policy
all new oh yeah so I I can't like like
tell me that so new is any any
distribution that uh can be generated by
some police
so uh yeah so this is like a very
informal in the center like like in the
real expression you can kind of choose
this new in the hindsight
yeah so so new is defined to be like
this
so essentially like they are they are
defining as like the uh distribution
such that like your uh your error can be
translated from let's say from the data
to that new distribution
right
so everything seems to be very great
right so we can't solve the offline our
problem we kind of can have like
learnable guarantees so what is really
amazing what should I talk about in the
second half of my talk so if you pay
attention like the guarantee I've been
talking about relies on a critical fact
which is I selecting the right
hyperprint of beta right and this beta
depends on you know many things I don't
really know like such as the real
measure of this like complexity of my
function class Etc right this is not
something I can actually get in practice
but when we choose the wrong beta value
I would say right I'll say incorrectly
we actually lose all the guarantees in
the into the degree that we cannot even
guarantee that uh the learn policy will
be better better than the data
collection policy and everything about
this is a very strange since because you
can use this uh Behavior policy to
collect the data then this is something
that is already kind of working right so
we want to only do learning to be to get
something that's better than what you
what you had at the beginning so this
makes everything very unreliable and
this is not really the thought of this
particular design but in general is a
fact for any algorithm that is trying to
optimize for LCD
which part of the proof use the choice
of media
[Music]
so uh in this proof I need to kind of
use the beta to actually get this like
two error specifically
um and and uh I also need a beta to kind
of like I think the lower back Parts
part okay but right like
so this part is okay this part can work
for any beta but the the part that about
like the exact size of this
uh matters uh in the beta codes and we
actually want to let's say especially we
want to show that Thelma error is very
small but we do not minimize the matter
directly right we minimize the sum of
them and error which is e and the other
terms and this comes from by Beta so we
need to factor in into the effects of
how beta is to bet and then to control
how exactly by my error will be right if
I step out let's say beta to be zero
then it's not going to minimize by my
area at all and therefore like this like
error of comma error uh 10 will be huge
essentially like you can think about
that you are over constraining uh your
uh function class and then that will
kind of not include the true one and
then you lose security
uh that will kind of increase the
essentially the uh
you basically you'll be over fitting to
the data and then it will essentially so
increase this like uh error in a
different way so basically this error
you get this expression at the End by
basically balancing the data uh and then
uh and that's how we got this final
expression and at the end the way we
balance the beta is to choose this
particular form
right and this is roughly think about
essentially like like if you think about
this as a considering a country I want
to constrain let's say two functions
that are let's say uh have that low
let's say error right if I said this I
have some of this content to be too
large and then there will be let's say
two loose if I decided to be let's say
uh too small then it will kind of
exclude the true function right and this
kind of is the center of beta right so
so essentially if you set this LCB to be
incorrect or be too like not very
precise then essentially the regret that
you get will essentially have this like
error depending on this part and if
there's two loose and to a degree then
you lose any guarantees that's the issue
and the the thing I'm trying to argue
here is that in practice very hard to
kind of set that to be precisely right
that's what we want from the theater in
there you can do that but it's hard to
do that in practice
yeah and this is not really like it's a
generic issue of using LCP uh and to
optimize performance
so the question here is can we design an
algorithm for offline RL that is more
robust to such a choice or hybrid
parameters because as I mentioned that I
mean a fully offline setting I don't
really know how to select this type of
print because I cannot interact with
online uh with the environment to really
try out whether this hyperpreneur is
good or bad
so the idea that we have is to change
the objective from the original five
which optimize for General Pi directly
but now instead to optimize for the
performance difference between 0 of Pi
and G of B so uh we have the same
regretation but we change the
differential Phi and the reason we come
with this new expression is similar to
the reason why we we used for the
previous one which is that this
expression has the same object break
from as this performance difference that
we want to optimize and this equality is
known as performance difference demo so
it's due to this algebraic flow so you
see that since now we are only changing
basically the updated by a let's say a
constant offset and we are still using
the same algebraic argument about uh
choosing these uh objective file you can
naturally expect that all the things I
talked about earlier will go through
right and into a degree at the end we
can show that there's no regret and best
response scheme can also be used to
solve this relative version of the game
and this algorithm is known as attack or
adversarially Trend active critic which
is another thing that we propose in icml
this year
and uh so you might think about that
yeah I just changed objective from uh
the absolute one and to the constant
offset like a regret to the behavior
policy why should that matter because I
know let's say in online RL optimizing
for the policy performance directly or
optimizing for the regularly I exactly
the same thing right but the important
thing here is that they are completely
different of my oil and the reason for
that is because in an IRL the agent can
explore to reduce the uncertainty uh due
to let's say uh finite data or the
partial data but in offline I just stick
with whatever data set that you have at
the beginning and the alternatively
cannot be reduced and that's why
different choice in objective will
actually lead to very different results
at the end
so before going to the math let me give
you some intuition about like why
they're going to be different right so
suppose that you want to go to school
and you have like different options you
can take a bus you can walk you can bike
but depending on the traffic condition
uh they might take different amount of
time so like if you have a very nice
traffic taking a bus will be much faster
much faster than the other options on
the other hand if the traffic's bad they
might take the same amount of time
so now if I want to optimize my uh
efficiency to go to the school
if I consider the the worst case in the
absolute sense then all the three
options will have the same worst case
which is that which will be 30 minutes
and so like taking either of them will
be the same so this is why you will
conclude if I want to find a decision
that is Minimax optimal in the worst
case
okay
but on the other hand if I try to
optimize for the relative performance to
taking the bus then you will have a very
different conclusion so here you'll see
that the bus is the variable option
because for the other one in the worst
case they can be slower than taking the
bus right because in the worst case the
basically within this weakness uh
different hypothesis
so in this case it will be clear that we
should take the bus and this kind of
maybe consistent with our common
integration in this scenario and so so
far the point of this I exercise to tell
you that there's a difference between
these two objectives I haven't shown you
why the relative fund is better here yet
so but you now can kind of get a sense
about like if I can shift the objective
by a constant but because of this
uncertainty in this hypothesis class
which is due to missing data uh they're
always going to lead to a difference in
the solution that you pick at the end
any questions
what the numbers are incorrect for case
one I will need to be 25 to 15.
yeah yeah
foreign
so
now let me dive a little bit deeper and
to compare the let's say the properties
of the two
so uh I'm going to compare that in terms
of the lower bound they're optimizing
and performance guarantee that we can
get right so this is the following the
logic that I discussed about the
absolute pessimist and case people
um so first they're all automatically
lower bounds uh since on the left hand
side we're constructing the lower Bound
for the absolute one uh sorry the the
five based on the the expression of the
absolute performance is optimizing the
lower bound of the absolute performance
and for the right hand side since I did
that for this difference and naturally
you you can show that like it's
automatic for a lower Bank of the
performance difference JPI manager of me
and then similarly by the optimality of
optimizing lower bound you can get a
regret guarantee uh to any comparator
based on essentially how much you
underestimate the comparative
right so we have seen that the left hand
side you have the underestimation error
in the absolute performance and
naturally you expected now you get a lot
of a upper boundary regret as the
underestimation error for the relative
performance of these competitors which
is zero Pi prime minister of mu right so
everything has very natural like uh
extension from the uh the absolute case
to the relative case
but in addition to that there's one
critical property that the absolute one
doesn't have which is uh this robust
policy Improvement property or RPI and
this follows from that the fact that
this relative one is optimizing for
lower bound of the relative performance
and so uh this kind of basically follows
from the the fact that I'm going to be
and the solution is like Minimax optimal
for the lower bank for the relative
lower bank and so basically it shows
that uh for any beta greater than or
equal to zero at least for this for this
population version the learn policy is
always going to be no worse than the uh
then the uh
the heavier policy on the other hand we
don't have that for the absolute person
you have to pick the right beta value to
in order to compete with the behavior
problems
okay
uh we can also understand why we have
this like a robust policy about like no
policy degradation from a different
perspective which is through a
connection between uh imitation learning
and offline reinforcement learning
established by this relative version of
the game or attack
and the main idea is that so in this
game we have uh actually Integrity which
is a policy and this hypothesis so we
can think about this actor and critic as
a generator and a discriminator in let's
say again like a genetic adversarial
Network formulation of the imitation
learning or imitation learning based on
like IPA
um
and by choosing different beta value we
can essentially control the strength of
the discriminator so for example if I
set beta to b0 which will be completely
removing this abdominal regardation term
so this will be essentially rough like
currently invitation learning with an
IPO with a Watson distance between the
distribution of the data and our policy
right so in that case the episode will
be the strongest and the only way to
compete with such adversary will be to
mimic the data exactly right so we see
that even when beta is equal to zero we
recover the behavior policy and that's
why there's no degradation on the other
hand when we increase beta we're going
to weaken the discriminator to let it to
be more data consistent and in that case
we recovered the offline our behavior of
uh let's say this algorithm
so in other words we show that there's a
connection between basically equivalence
between offline arrow with like relative
estimation and and that is equal to like
imitation learning with abundant
regretation on the basis on the
discriminator
and this is essentially why we get this
RPI property because I regarding how I
set the beta because I will kind of
reduce to the the very natural sense
right so let me present the formal
guarantees that we can have for this
relative framework so firstly is the uh
regret but I'm going to save you the
trouble here and just to tell you that
this page is exactly the same as why I
show you for the apps again so you get
the same guarantees as the absolute
pessimism which means that if I pick the
beta red value to be right I can
complete with any data uh sorry cover
policy as the other offline algorithm
can do
but now we have this extra property this
RPI property and it basically shows that
if my Beta is not super huge it has to
be something 99 for that I'm going to
tell you why later and uh because now we
have in the finance sample case so if
base is not huge then I can compete with
the the behavior policy uh up to
sunlight statistical error in
optimization error okay
it is beautiful something special here
or if suppose I had another policy this
performance
[Music]
oh you can use yeah it's better that's
very good so uh you cannot do that with
the model 3 version but you can do that
with a model based three so in another
place version I can have this RPM
property not to the behavior policy but
to any reference I want
the
question
as for that
like I should be able like I should have
some idea about F5 is what that
reference is oh so so you need to have a
function so as I mentioned you can only
do that in the model Class A model based
version so what it means what you need
is a unique reference policy
and you need to have a model class that
kind of contents it through the settings
yeah but that would be not sufficient
and the reason for that is because that
uh
you want to come like whenever sorry
picks this hypothesis you want to make
sure that you are evaluating let's say
your policy and the thing you're
comparing to under the same hypothesis
right so if you not only know the let's
say uh s specific Cube type for the the
two of the compare with which is a
baseline but when you pick the adversary
kick let's say the Q5 or the F-type for
the your learner's policy if they are
kind of like in also different entities
then you don't have a way to argue that
they are going to be comparable to worst
case it's very important that like when
you do this optimization you're asking
Michael for a relative error and this is
defined uh under the same potential
hypothesis that is adversaristic and
trying to pick the adversary repeat the
worst case hypothesis such that the
differences Technologies
right so and then for this RPI property
uh one nice thing is that it requires
even a weaker assumption on the function
class F which is not requiring this like
completing this assumption and the
intuition here is that because you
already seen that this RPI probably
mostly comes from the imitation learning
Behavior so imitation learning basically
throw away development organization turn
and complaint is essentially uh needed
for that loan so um so you can basically
get an extra bonus in robustness in
terms of like uh function uh like error
that you have
so a quick proof of this is like this so
uh again I'm going to just substitute
the definition of my mixture policy and
then I'm going to add and subtract the
uh the lower bound I estimate about the
reality performance
and then I'm going to expand the
definition of Phi to its original form
and now we have two turns
so the thing on the green one is the
regret which is that the same thing we
saw uh in the uh like the absolute
version as well
uh this orange thing is essentially uh
the difference between the uh the true
performance difference and the lower
bound that we estimated so ideally this
pattern should be negative because we
are constructing a lower bound right but
there are some residuals in here and and
that's because that uh these files is
defined under the data distribution and
we have to approximate that by samples
and that's why you have this extra
noising here uh so if you adopt another
based version this orange 10 will
disappear but for the model 3 version
you'll pay for something like this
because I'm not it's not like that
loadback it's a lower bound
approximately by for the approximately
by samples
[Music]
is a complexity of the function class
and the policy class so let's say it's a
log of let's say number of functions
that you have
roughly or the current number eventually
right so just to recap what we have
covered so far so I talked about two
different versions of this game
theoretical Purge one is based on the
absolute pessimism the one space on the
relative person so if you think about
this like different kinds of pessimism
they actually have like their
counterparts in a more uh common let's
say a single entity approach by a single
NDP I mean that I construct NDP that is
more pessimistic than origin NDP and
optimize system are passing that
um so for the relative one the counter
problem will be something called
behavioralization which I algorithm uh
that kind of penalize the policy uh to
uh stay close to the behavior policy for
example using Cal Divergence
or anything sound like an imitation
learning turn
uh and this algorithm all have the RPI
property they are more robust to hyper
critical selections and really really
because they're let's say connection to
implementation
on the other hand we have everything
based on like absolute pessimism that as
I mentioned that we include algorithm
space I'm using negative bonuses or
calculation
uh and overall we can think about this
again theoretical approach uh versions
of these algorithms are less
conservative because they can better
leverage the structure of our uh prior
on the hypothesis class
when they pay a price which is that like
you need to solve for two players which
is a much harder problem than just I
optimizing businessing automatically
and that's kind of the issue
but suppose we can solve that right so
here I'm going to show that like Beyond
Theory we actually show that this idea
of like no regret and best response can
actually be used to design something
that's wrong about in practice and can
achieve the state-of-the-art empirical
performance in offline or benchmarks and
the way we do that is that we're going
to approximate this update rule by uh
stochastic gradient of the rules and
with two different time scales so we're
going to basically take gradients to
optimize these two objectives whether no
regret will be replaced by maximizing
the critic but I'm going to basically
let the critique to take a much larger
step size than than the actor so this is
counter to mimic the behavior of the
best response so given an actor I want
to kind of find the the hypothesis that
is the most pessimistic with respect to
that actor by any of the experiment
extended experiments we use like a
Stepside that's like a thousand times
larger than that so you can think about
these are actors I'm updating very
slowly and the grid is much much faster
uh and with this we can actually use
this algorithm to uh train deep neural
networks and we compare that with other
state-of-the-art like deep offline our
algorithms and just head to head in the
empirical performance
um so after this Arrow I don't have any
theoretical guarantees about what it
works but it's a kind of like uh
Implement that is based on the idea of
what we can prove
okay so uh we run the experiments on the
default our data sets which have and
then we picked plenty for data from that
Benchmark uh then there are like data
sets of continuous control problems of
different dimensions and and have
different data qualities from uh data
collected by random policies or uh extra
policy or mixture of multiple policies
and so first we found that this pspi
algorithm based on the absolute
pessimism uh kind of like it's almost at
the state of the art it kind of wins
almost all the Baseline in most cases
and we found that if we use a relative
version it's even better if it's even
all the Baseline in almost other cases
and uh and we get a like nine percent
Improvement in the performance among it
is for like one and a half of data sets
that we tested
no so in the empirical version we're
trying new another policy and we just
use the last one
yeah
yeah yeah
numbers better here yeah
so they're suggested of course we are
departing that area but uh that we're
gonna compete with the behavior for this
year at least but we see a bunch of
cases like relocated humans practices
absolutely not happening right right so
so uh yeah so you'll see most of the
case yeah better than the vehicle policy
yeah but not for the human kids and the
reason is because I hear about using
microbial policy and this data set is
collected by women which is
I have different information
that
yeah when you see that yeah it's not
country yeah mostly
okay
so uh yeah so in addition to the episode
that this RPI property can be during
practice as far it is like how you
really say sort of implementation
because of this time
um so here we compare how the algorithm
performs under different bank account
values right and then I'm going to
compare how it works with the absolute
record and the relative version so here
the uh the orange one or the kind of red
orange one it knows the performance of
the absolute version and the blue one
denotes the relative version and the
green one is the performance of the
behavior policy
so in all these experiments uh on the
data set that are showing here like we
found that the relative version
outperforms the behavior policy for all
the beta value except for very large
ones and that is exactly what our theory
predicts right remember that we need the
beta to be sublingual number and it
cannot be super large otherwise the
noise will blow up right so with this we
see this is true and roughly the reason
why this against mutationally if I tune
this algorithm that Implement uh with
like very small beta value it's kind of
doing less imitation learning with get
yeah
um figure pay doesn't seem to be true
yeah so there is like an error bar in
there
yeah
and then all of that I want they're kind
of the most difficult data Technologies
for this
approximate beside roughly through
almost
yeah this is something that's super
surprising to her because yeah we found
we had a theory already
it's kind of very like hesitant to us to
see what that's doing perfectly or not I
mean surprising that yeah
so which is very nice uh anyone's gonna
see that this is not true for the uh
absolute version
so like if you set the uh they had to be
around to be very small it can be very
very uh badly
okay so yeah let me summary uh summarize
the talk so basically today I talk about
again theoretical approach to offline RL
and it's based on the idea of having a
learner to compete with an adversary in
a two-player game or a stackable game
and we showed that this approach can be
used to systematically design a
algorithm for offline RL with peripheral
guarantees and they also have very like
uh I mean reusable uh practical
approximations
um so I talked about two versions I
mostly focus on another free version and
they kind of just differ in terms of
their objective fight and uh actually
both cases have like learning automatic
guarantees if you choose the right beta
value we design magical number then uh
you can basically compare with the best
cover policy as any other offline our
policy algorithm can do but they are
kind of being let's pessimistic than
their point wise version
uh for the relative one we have this
epsilonized property called RPI and then
which allows you to kind of be robust to
hypermeister selection right and this
property is kind of used for uh to
Applications where the decisions can be
super critical you don't want to make a
mistakes like let's say uh in the
healthcare applications and it can also
sometimes be used to do a hangout tuning
if your application you allow let's say
running a policy that is better than the
behavior policy to in online then what I
can do is I can start from beta equal to
zero and gradually increase the beta to
kind of fine tune the performance of the
algorithm and guarantee that while doing
so I'm not going to have any policy
performance degradation if so if that's
allowed then you can use this property
to do extra fine tune if you want
uh okay so uh this is the last slide uh
so I want to just briefly mention that
all the things I talked about have a
very natural extension to the model
based case and the thing you'll need to
do is just to change what a hypothesis
is so in the model 3 a hypothesis is a
function of Stand action in the model
based one hypothesis will never be a
model right and then the regularization
to enforce data consistency will be kind
of like model fitting error like these
are the word difference and not likely
so for the absolute pessimism again the
natural definition of this objective
will be just the absolute performance of
a policy under this model right and this
is actually a known algorithm which is a
follow-up work of our original paper and
this algorithm is called cppo
uh we can do the same for the uh
relative version and in that case the
objective will be just like the
performance difference under the model
and
as I mentioned that in this version it's
even nicer that you can even change the
the uh mu to a different policy that you
have a space whether it's sticking with
the view and you also have like a
smaller like you remove from the
statistical error that we have seen in
RPI uh so this is the ongoing work that
we we are about to kind of put on
libraries
um yeah but finally I wanted to
mentioned that I feel like there's still
like many managements that we can
explore in this space uh in let's say
choosing five choosing this
regularization uh choosing what a
hypothesis class is and also like
choosing how we actually optimize for
design two player again right y presents
are very preliminary and kind of natural
choices that you probably will try in
the first step but I think like there
are still like many possibilities that
we can explore in this space and I think
they are like very uh interesting
research directions
uh yeah so finally if you are interested
uh I'll invite you to read the papers
and then you can if you really want to
want to run the experiments and actually
you you will but you can find a code
online open source as well yeah thank
you
is inside
despair oh yeah yeah so uh the real
thing the we need to kind of approximate
it by the regret in the regression
so so you can't like comparison
yeah or you can do let's say uh I have a
Target and then I can't like uh meeting
my specifically the exactly so basically
I have the square error and minimize
let's say uh that versus the uh
yeah
yeah
the right working space for the you know
the theory uh empirically we just use it
happening
listen yeah
yeah so that part can yeah there's a
square time so you can directly to it
I'm enjoying this person
do you have like some Google
notifications
like just in the that's why I know the
robust spots
um
yeah yeah so the the main difference
especially uh it's in a very high level
is how you measure the support
so uh most existing algorithms measure
the support based on the kind of data so
for example I uh I can only let's say
configuration policy uh whose State
identity ratio compared with the
behavioral thoughts in this topic right
you define a support based on the
density uh whereas here we can't Define
a support based on let's say uh how much
uh basically the region where your error
will generate
right so let's say uh if this is not a
very good example in here suppose in
this color example
all your functions address on the right
hand side let's say something like
collapse right so that would be
essentially like places where your
function increase based on your as a
hypothesis but you have to zero data
and so uh This Record can basically
allows you to generate to those regions
as well and basically you don't really
measure the average there on the other
hand uh if I do something that's been
more close to let's say I'm trying to
make my process mistake because the
daily traditional some Foundation based
on uh
particular measure then I I can't have a
like a tighter sorry a smaller region
that I can actually generate so that's
kind of the main difference in a bigger
future uh there's for both diversity and
actual version the guarantees are almost
similar for the performance
thank you speakers